المترجم: Hassan Athab
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
من أنت ؟ومن أنتِ؟
هذا هو السؤال الأكثر شيوعاً
الذي نتساءل به أو نسأل به
في الأماكن العامة، في المطارات
حتى إن كنت في مطعم تتناول وجبة الطعام.
هنالك 2,4 مليار فقير حول العالم
1,5 مليار منهم فوق سن الرابعة عشر
لا يستطيعون أن يعرفوا عن أنفسهم
بالطريقة التي ترضي السلطات
هل من حل لهذه المعضلة؟
دائما التقنية تملك الحل.
إنها تقنية البلوكتشين
قبل أن أتحدث عن البلوكتشين
وعن هذه التقنية وغيرها من التقنيات
أريد أن أمشي معكم في سياق زمني
عن تطور الثورات الصناعية وكيف وصلنا
إلى هذه الثورة العظيمة جداً.
بدايةً، الإنسان البدائي الذي كان دائما
يقتات على ما تنتجه الأرض من ثمرات
وكان دائما لا يستقر في مستوطنات
إنما ينتقل من مكان إلى آخر
حسب وجود هذه الخيرات
التي يستطيع الإقتات عليها
إلى أن تعلم الزراعة وتمضي بنا الأيام
حتى القرن الثامن عشر حيث بدأت الثورة
الصناعية الأولى
بدأت ملامح الثورة الصناعية الأولى
باكتشاف الآلة البخارية
أو باختراع الآلة البخارية عفواً.
حيث استطاعوا تحويل خط الإنتاج
إلى خطوط إنتاج أكبر
وأصبحت هناك منتجات قابلة للبيع
ومنتجات قابلة لنقل البضائع
عن طريق سكك القطارات من مكان إلى آخر
ثم دخلنا الثورة الصناعية الثانية
التي بدأت باكتشاف التيار الكهربائي
ودخلت فيها الماكينات والآلات
وخطوط الانتاج الكبيرة جداً
والمعروف بالانتاج الضخم
ثم انتقلنا إلى الثورة الصناعية الثالثة
التي دخلت فيها الحاسب الآلي
وعمليات الأتمتة وعمليات الإنتاج الآلي
حيث أصبحت العمليات بشكل أكبر
واختراع الانترنت حيث سهلت
المعاملات ما بين الناس
وسهلت أشياء كثيرة جداً جداً
الآن
في هذه الحقبة التي نعيش فيها
الثورة الصناعية الرابعة
حددها العلماء أنها بدأت في العام 2010
ما هي الثورة الصناعية الرابعة؟
الثورة الصناعية الرابعة
هي نقلة نوعية كبيرة جداً جداً
في مختلف الأصعدة
الأصعدة الحياتية: المدن الذكية
العقود الذكية، إنترنت الأشياء،
الذكاء الأصطناعي
تعلم الآلات
ومن ضمنها تقنية البلوكتشين
التي أريد أن أحدثكم عنها اليوم.
البلوكتشين هي سلسلة الكتل المعروفة
أنها عبارة عن شبكة تستخدم مبدأ الند للند
بحيث يرسل العميل طلب
تسجّل هذه العملية في الشبكة
كما تشاهدون هنا
يقوم الشخص بطلب العملية
تنتشر عبر شبكة الند للند
التي تكون منتشرة حول العالم
ثم يتم التحقق من معلومات هذه العملية
بعد التحقق
تدخل هذه العملية في كتلة
كل كتلة تلتصق بالكتلة التي خلفها
أو التي بعدها
بشكل تلقائي غير قابلة للتعديل،
غير قابلة للحذف
بعد عملية التحقق
تدخل إلى باقي الكتل
ثم تتم العملية بنجاح.
ماذا يمكن أن تقدم هذه البلوكتشين؟
استخدامات البلوكتشين واسعة جداً
في المجال المالي، في المجال الحركي،
في المجال الصحي، في المجال الإداري،
في المجال العسكري أيضاً
دعوني أحدثكم عن الجانب المالي
وعن العملة التي أثارت جدلاً كبيراً
في العالم "البتكوين"
ما هي البتكوين؟
البتكوين هي عملة رقمية
محددة بواحد وعشرين مليون عملة فقط
بدأت من عام 2008
كتبها شخص أو مجموعة
بكود "ساتوشي ناكاموتو"
هذا هو الكود المسمى
لا أحد يعلم من هو هذا الشخص
كتبه في 2008 وبدأ التدوال فيها في 2009
كان سعر العملة الواحدة في 2009، 67 سنت
اليوم سعر العملة هو 10,900 دولار
وليس ريال
البتكوين الواحد بما يعادل
أكثر من 40 الف ريال
وصلت إلى أعلى ذروتها في 2017
شهر ديسمبر 20 الف دولار
لماذا تملك البتكوين
هذا الزخم والسعر الكبير جداً؟
البتكوين هي ذهب رقمي
لها تنقيب يسمى تنقيب البتكوين
تعد وتنقب عن طريق أجهزة رقمية
مثل كروت الشاشة والمعالجات
وتحتاج إلى طاقة حاسوبية جداً قوية
لتنقيب البتكوين
حوالي كل 10 دقائق إلى 12 دقيقة ونصف
تنتج بتكوين حول العالم.
البتكوين... يقال أنها عدو البنوك الأول
لأنها تلغي فكرة الطرف الثالث
أن يكون هناك بنك مركزي يتحكم
بإصدار هذه العملة
لا يوجد بنك يصدرها
لا يوجد أي شخص يمتلكها امتلاك حصري
هي غير مركزية وآمنة جداً
أستطيع أن أحول لك الآن
مجرد أن أفتح كود المحفطة
وبعمل الفحص للباركود
سترسل لك خلال نصف ساعة
في أي مكان حول العالم
ومهما كانت كمية البتكوين
هناك شخص حول 177 مليون دولار
بعمولة سنتات
سنتات فقط
وهذا ما يميز البتكوين العملات الرقمية
بأنها لا تحتاج إلى عمولة كبيرة للتحويل
"ويسترن بونين" لتحويل 3000 ريال،
تحتاج تقريباً إلى 150 ريال
و10 آلاف يزداد إلى 200 ثم إلى 300
فتخيلوا هذه العملة كم تحل من المشاكل
من التحويلات الدولية الكبيرة
ما بين الدول والشركات العملاقة
البتكوين...
نصيحة أخ، وخصوصاً للآباء والأمهات
إذا أردتم الخير لأبنائكم
اشتروا لهم بتكوين
يوجد توقعات، أنه سيصل سعرها في 2020
إلى 100 ألف دولار
وإلى الآن، لا تزال البتكوين
في مراحلها الأولى
هذه بعض استخدامات البلوكتشين
والبتكوين حول العالم
أوربا، كندا، أمريكا اللاتينية، الصين
استراليا، الهند
في الشرق الأوسط، يقول لي الكثيرون
كلما أتكلم عن البتكوين
"البتكوين ممنوعة"، "البتكوين مجرّمة"
لا، البتكوين غير مشرعنة
القصة فقط التشريعات الواضحة
حتى يستطيع الناس أن يتداولوها في ما بينهم
والذهاب للمحكمة في حال حصول شيء.
وتأكدت من ذلك بالاتصال الهاتفي
بمؤسسة النقد العربي السعودي
وكان السؤال هو
"إذا تعاملت بالبتكوين، بعت بتكوين لأحد
وأخذت ريال سعودي، هل ارتكبت خطأ؟"
لا، ليس عليك أي جرم قانوني.
أتمنى قريباً رؤية المملكة العربية السعودية
ودول الخليج ضمن هذه الدول "بإذن الله"
ماذا بعد؟
العالم الآن يتسارع بخطى سريعة جداً
الثورة الصناعية الرابعة تنتقل نقلات فلكية
المدن الذكية، العقود الذكية
أين نحن من هذه القافلة
إحدى الطرق هي إنشاء مشروع
وتسمية عملة باسمه
وأخذ دعم من الناس عن طريق هذه العملة
نوع من التمويل الجماعي
مثلاُ عملة "عزام كوين"، وعندي مشروع معين
أضعها في "Market Cap"
وتكون في كارد المشروع
وتتداولوا معي، وتشتروا هذه العملة
فتكون مكسباً للجميع
يطلع سعر العملة، تبيعه فيما بعد
فتكسب أنت وأنا أكسب ايضاً
أتمنى أن أجد مشاريع شبابية كبيرة جداً
وأتمنى أن أجد عملات عربية
يوجد عملة عربية اسمها "دبي كوين"
هناك مشروع سعودي- إماراتي مشترك
لإنشاء عملة
قريباً سترى الضوء
فيسبوك، أعلن عن عملة اسمها "ليبرا"
أحدثت ضجة كبيرة جداً
لدرجة أن دونالد ترامب نفسه تكلم عنها
وعندما يتكلم السياسي عن موضوع
فلابد أنه خائف منه
على أن اليبرا والبتكوين مبنية على
الـ "Thin Air"
فهي ليست على الـ Thin Air أبداً
هذه البتكوين هي العدو الأول للدولار
لذلك تتم الحرب الإعلامية
والترهات التي تحدث
ألقاكم على خير
عزام المحمدي
شكراً جزيلاً لكم